each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available hello hi everyone um I'm Madan
maati from the research and software
engineering group and it's my pleasure
to introduce use Dan Marino today um he
is no stranger he spent two internship
with us um hacking on compilers and he's
graduating from UCLA he works with uh
Todd milstein at UCLA and he he did his
undergraduate and UC Berkeley and then
he worked in the industry for 5 years
before he decided that he was getting
paid too much and he went back to
graduate school and um so at graduate
school he's been working on uh different
aspects of programming languages and
today he's going to be talking about um
how to give semantics to concr
programming languages Dan thanks M and
thanks everybody for coming um all right
so parallel programming is hard uh and
here is just one illustration of why
that's the case um you take this simple
C++ program that has two variables and
exactly two
threads uh and the thread T here sets
the variable X to be some newly
allocated memory and then sets the init
flag to true and thread U over here uh
tests that init flag and only if it's
set to true then it goes ahead and
dereferences x and so the question we
want to ask ourselves for this parallel
program is can this crash and in
particular can we get a a ND reference
uh a segmentation fault here at at
statement D and if you don't spend a lot
of time thinking about the low-level
details of concurrent languages or about
memory models then you probably would
say this program looks fine uh but in
fact it can
crash um and so if parallel programming
is so hard as a programmer I might think
you know forget this concurrency stuff
I'm just going to continue writing my
sequential code uh I've Gotten Good at
that so I'll just do that
instead uh and but there's a problem
with this and that you know comes back
to Moore's Law right so we have this uh
graph showing the transistor count
doubling every two years or so uh and
that's that's continued all the way up
to the present day but the architecture
landscape uh is changing and these
transistors are getting used in a new
way and so you know five years back or
more uh we started hitting physical
constraints that stopped us from being
able to use these transistors to sort of
make deeper pipelines and increase clock
speeds and instead we saw the number of
cores uh on a chip uh being uh
increasing and so instead of having this
sort of familiar model of a a a a CPU
talking to some number of levels of
cache and then talking to memory
architecture started changing and you
they started looking more like this
where you had many CPUs and maybe many
different caches and eventually they're
all sort of can talk to the same shared
memory up here at the
top and so this sort of fundamental
change down at the architecture level uh
trickles up to the programmer and so
this programmer who's become accustomed
to having his programs run faster uh if
he just Waits a for the faster
processors to come out or to be able to
add new features without sacrificing
performance or to have his algorithms
work on bigger problems simply by
waiting that's not going to work anymore
he's not going to get this sort of free
lunch that he's gotten from mors law in
the past unless he can start thinking
about his program in in a parallel way
and and uh allow it to scale in this
way
okay so if our program is going to be
forced to think about uh to to code in
parallel then let's see how he might
reason about this example program we had
think okay how could these different
threads be
interleaved um well it could be that
thread T runs entirely first and then
followed by thread U and in that case
then uh you know we'll we'll set X to
this newly allocated memory we'll set in
it to true this will C uh init equal to
true and then D reference X everything
looks okay because X has already been
initialized oh but we could have the
case where this uh inter leaving where
actually C executes in between a and b
in that situation well when C executes
and it's still going to be false uh its
initial value uh and so D won't be
executed at all again no program crash
looks okay and you can apply the same
reasoning if you sort of look at this
other inter
leing so okay that was kind of hard
especially for a four-line program um to
have to reason about that but the
program looks okay um but I said that
this program could crash so what's
what's the flaw here um and the thing is
this programmer isn't sort of
considering all of the stuff that's
going on uh underneath the covers uh
across this this Hardware software stack
and in fact when the optimizing compiler
and Hardware get their hands on this
program uh they choose to do their
optimizations you know looking only at
one thread at a time and in fact they
might say hey statement B doesn't depend
on statement a they access different
variables there's no sort of data
dependence or control dependence there
uh might be faster to go ahead and
reorder
those so if either the compiler or the
hardware does that then we end up with
uh this situation where this interner
leaving that's suggested here could
happen and indeed that would cause a
null pointer to reference because uh C
would see an it equal to True before X
had been
initialized so why I mean why do we want
to do these reorderings anyway uh and
it's because uh there's you know been a
lot of research and and we've come to
rely on our compilers to give us code
that performs well by performing
optimizations such as common
subexpression elimination and register
promotion and smart instruction
scheduling and all of these different
optimizations have the potential to
reorder
accesses uh similarly at the hardware we
have out of order execution and things
like store buffers to try and hide the
latency of cash misses for instance and
these uh same features also will uh
cause memory accesses to be
reordered and so what that means is that
when we were in the sequential world the
programming language had the same strong
sequential semantics that you you
expected but now that we're coding in
this parallel world we still want these
performance optimizations that we've
come to rely on but then we have to have
these weak semantics up at the
programming language level um where we
have to reason about our memory access
as potentially being
reordered and
so the result of this current approach
approach of of allowing all of these
optimizations and then uh putting up
with these weak semantics is that we
have nasty bugs uh we all know that
concurrency bugs are difficult to track
down because they may only happen
intermittently on certain code paths and
certain inter leavings uh and they can
have serious consequences I just have a
couple of examples up here of situations
where concurrency bugs caused uh
expensive uh were very expensive and
even caused death in the case of this
radiation therapy machine and so as we
see you know increasing number of
parallel programs because our
programmers are being forced to code in
this parallel style and we're seeing
increasing core counts you can only
extrapolate this and think we're going
to see even more of these nasty bugs uh
as we move
forward and uh I think that we can
definitely do better here uh and I think
we can do better by taking a a kind of a
holistic approach uh and we can get we
can allow programmers to develop these
fast and safe concurrent programs by
exploiting cooperation among these
different layers of the hardware and
software
stack so I'm going to talk about two
main projects today I'm going to spend
most of my time talking about
drfx um which is uh it it is uh it gives
straightforward programming language
level semantics to a concurrent
programming language uh while still
allowing efficient implementation by
taking advantage of cooperation uh
across this stack and then I'm also
going to talk uh that's what I'm going
to spend most of my time talking about
I'll also later talk a little bit about
light race uh which was uh a tool I
built
for um that uses sampling in order to
have a a high performance data race
detector and a data race is a a common
kind of concurrency
bug okay so first I'm going to talk
about drfx uh and to uh first what I
need to do is Define what a memory model
is so one way to define a memory model
is that it defines the order in which
memory operations can execute or the
order in which they be can become
visible to other threads in the system
and so as you can see from this
definition a memory model is actually
essential in order to describe the
behavior of a concurrent program um
because you know if you don't know what
memory rights are visible to what reads
in different threads then you can't you
know say how your program is going to
behave
so one memory model is sequential
consistency it was introduced by Leslie
Lamport way back in
1979 and uh the idea with sequential
consistency is that memory operations uh
appear to occur in some Global Order
that's consistent with the program order
and they appear that way to all threads
in the system so it's basically an
interleaving semantics and this is in
fact what our programmer who mistakenly
thought that program couldn't crash
earlier he was using this this sort of
SC memory model and so that's you know
basically thought of as the most
intuitive memory model that we can
provide but it disallows a lot of these
optimizations that I mentioned earlier
and so the current state-of-the-art for
programming language memory models are
these data Race Free models or drf Z
models and they give this intuitive
sequentially consistent behavior that we
want for a certain class of programs
data rasf free programs um but the for
other programs it provides much weaker
semantics so the idea with drf zero uh
is that programmers uh are encouraged to
use and in fact often do use sort of
highle
synchronization uh constructs in order
to communicate between threads like
locks and signal at weight um and so the
compiler agrees not to sort of do
anything crazy with its optimizations
with respect to these uh operations and
the compiler also can communicate that
down to the the hardware using fences
and and translates these into uh Atomic
operations and the hardware is
restricted from reordering around those
operations and a program is considered
data Race Free if the programmer has
included enough of these synchronization
operations so that no two conflicting
accesses that is two accesses to the
same memory location where at least one
is a right so that no two conflicting
accesses to Shared memory can execute
concurrently so if you have enough
synchronization if you have a well
synchronized program then your program's
data race free and we get this SC
behavior that we want under these drf
models but uh we get weak or no
semantics for rais programs so the Java
memory model is an example uh of one of
these drf zero models uh and it it
provides a a much more complicated
semantics for your language uh if or for
your program if it contains data races
uh C++ uh the new C++ Ox memory model is
kind of an extreme version of the data
Race Free models where they give
absolutely no semantics uh to a program
that contains data
races so just coming back to our example
program here um you actually can make
this a data race free program uh for
instance in the in the new C++ uh Ox you
can do that by specifying that this init
flag uh you add the atomic keyword there
and that indicates that it's being used
for
synchronization uh and then uh the
compiler and the hardware are prevented
from performing the these problematic
reorderings that we saw
earlier
okay so what's the
problem with the rfzo memory
model well basically it's that it's very
difficult to determine whether or not a
particular program has a data race um
there are for instance type systems for
race freedom but they're Limited in
their applicability because they
generally apply to uh lock based code uh
limited styles of synchronization uh or
if if they're if they support more
anetic analyses tend to be conservative
or if they support different uh you know
many variants of uh synchronization then
they they don't scale well to large
programs um so that's in the static
world in the in the dynamic world it's
it's not enough because uh testing
you're only testing certain Paths of a
program you don't get full coverage and
so uh you may miss some in leavings you
may miss some paths uh and so you won't
find all the data races in your program
uh furthermore Dynamic analyses tend to
be very expensive uh for detecting races
slowing down your program by adex or or
much more than that in some
cases uh and the fact it's easy to
introduce data race you know you can see
that this is actually true by just I I
did a quick uh search of some bugzilla
databases uh and saw and found bug
reports that were unresolved and had
race condition in their description and
you know here for Mozilla we had 122 of
them in MySQL we had 12 so these are you
know real bugs that happen all the time
uh
and so we end up with this really for
these programs we end up with this weak
semantics or no semantics at all um for
our programs so sort of a summary of
this is that if we have weak or no
sematics for racy programs and it's easy
to unintentionally introduce data
races well that's problematic for debug
ability because our programmers need to
assume that they're seeing non-sc
behavior for all their programs because
they're not sure whether or not there's
a race in there it's problematic for
safety um in their PDI paper bow and his
co-authors showed how reasonable
compiler optimizations that are
sequentially valid when combined with a
program that has a data race can
actually cause your code to take a wild
branch and jump to start executing
arbitrary
code um and that's exactly you know
that's one of the main reasons why in
the C++ Ox memory model they give no
semantics to a racy program because this
kind of thing might
happen um now in Java they didn't have
the luxury uh of of saying we're not
going to give any semantics because they
have these safety guarantees they need
to maintain uh and so they have this you
know rather complex description of what
program behaviors are allowed in the
presence of a data race um but it turns
out that it's so complicated it's really
very difficult to tell if a particular
compiler optimization is even admitted
by the model and in fact SE Che and
Aspen showed that uh that certain
compiler optimizations that were
explicitly intended to be allowed by the
model in fact we not uh and so it's it's
difficult to reason with with these kind
of memory models
so our solution uh to this was the drfx
memory
model and uh in this memory model we
take the approach that a data race is a
programming error uh and as such we
should feel free to terminate a program
at runtime if a data race is
detected okay and uh by allowing
ourselves this freedom and uh as I'll
show you by using cooperation between
the compiler and the hardware we get a
memory model that has good debug ability
we're going to give sequential
consistency for all
executions um it it's it's a safe
programming model because uh we're going
to Halt a program before any non-sc
behavior is exhibited and it's easy to
determine what compiler optimizations
are allowed basically all sequentially
valid optimizations are going to be
allowed with a few restrictions that
I'll describe
later uh and so with this Hardware
compiler code design and and the ability
to throw this exception we end up with
strong end to-end guarantees from The
Source language down to the actual
execution of the compiled code um with a
9% slowdown on
average so let's take a look at at what
the memory model guarantees okay um the
first part of the guarantee is if you
give if the programmer gives you a data
Ras free source
program then all executions of that
program will be sequentially
consistent however if there's a race in
the program the program may be
terminated with a memory model
exception so with the picture the way it
looks so far it seems like we need some
precise runtime data race detection um
but that's slow uh if you try and do
that in software and Hardware Solutions
are very
complex um but we actually have an
escape hatch
here if your program has data raises we
don't have to raise an exception we can
go ahead and allow the program to
continue executing as long as we can
guarantee that the behavior that we're
seeing is sequentially consistent so we
take advantage of that uh in order to
simplify the runtime detection
process Yeah question so you say that uh
if the program has some dat rais it may
be raising an exception may be raised or
must be raised may be raised okay yeah
we have two options if if the if the
original program has a data race and
we're running
it if that data race is going to result
in SE Behavior then we non Behavior then
we absolutely must throw a memory model
exception if that data race is in in
somehow is is you know exhibited but
doesn't cause non behavior and we can
somehow guarantee that we're still going
to get sequential consistency then we
don't need to raise
it so let's take a look at at how we do
this um here's our example program for
earlier without that Atomic keyword so
um so this is a racy program we've got a
race on both X and on the init
variable and here's that problematic
interleaving
and this could have been done by the
compiler this this reordering of these
accesses so our Insight was that the
compiler can actually communicate to the
hardware regions where it performed
optimizations regions in which it might
have reordered accesses in order to
optimize and it can do that using some
new kind of instruction called a region
fence um that tells the hardware where
these where these code regions
are now the hardware is respons
responsibility then is just to detect
conflicts you know read uh two axises to
the same memory location where at least
one is a right um among between regions
that execute concurrently so in this
problematic inter leaving these regions
definitely execute concurrently and so
the hardware needs to raise a memory
model
exception if on the other
hand the execution looked like
this well then you know we had this this
reorder occurred but it's not actually
causing any problems because you know it
it completes entirely before this other
region with which it races starts
executing and so we don't we don't we
still have a data race that's been
exhibited in this program there's no
happens before relation between these
regions there's no synchronization
operation forcing them to execute in one
order or the other but nonetheless we
can guarantee SE behavior and and so we
don't need to raise an exception and so
this is the simplification uh we don't
have to do full race detection we only
need to do data race detection on
concurrently executing regions that were
communicated by the compiler to the
hardware so we rely on this cooperation
and so there's a set of requirements
that the compiler and the hardware need
to obey uh in order to get our strong
guarantees that we're looking for uh so
that for its part the compiler uh
partitions each thread into regions by
using these region fence
instructions and it puts synchronization
operations in their own region and so
this stops in well synchronized program
this sort of stops any um regions that
have conflicting accesses from executing
concurrently and so we won't raise any
exceptions at
runtime uh it also agrees to optimize
only within a
region uh so it's limited in its scope
by these regions that it puts in but the
nice thing is that it can perform all of
the sequentially valid optimizations
that it wants to within that region
except that it can't introduce
speculative reads or wrs because that
could raise uh cause the hardware to
raise an exception in an otherwise
race-free
program for its part the hardware needs
to treat these fences as memory barriers
essentially not optimizing across
fences um but otherwise can do all the
reorderings it usually does uh and it
has to perform this conflict
detection so those that set of
requirements we've uh formally specified
them uh
and used them to establish the drfx
guarantees I'm sorry can you say a b
more what is a region fence and I'm
sorry this it's known to everybody in
But but so is it it's in forc basically
some
synchronization uh the region fence so
the region
fence the so the requirements are that
synchronization op uh synch
synchronization operations definitely
have to be in their own region right so
um in that sense they are related to
synchronization but they don't but
region fenes can be added uh in places
other than right where synchronization
operations are and I'm going to show you
later why we might want to do that okay
why it can be useful to actually put in
one of these
fences um even when there is no
synchronization so even with region
fences they can still be data races
correct there can be yes yes the region
fences don't do any additional
synchronization all they yeah they're
just delimiting where that
synchronization is it's more think
actually think of it more as an
annotation yeah versus something which
is we need synchronization and operation
which is for it it is an annotation but
it also stops the hardware from moving
memory accesses across it I see
sub so you said the compiler would
insert the region fence if it reordered
it if it reordered those two access is
between and and X right the question is
if the hardware if the compiler didn't
reorder it but the hardware did how
would it know that there should have
been a region around the hardware could
equally well do reorder it yes that's
correct and the hardware needs to okay
so whatever region fences the compiler
comes up
with the hardware also needs to will
detect conflicting access first of all I
should specify that everything's in a
region right there's nothing that's not
in a region so everything's in a region
and the comp and the hardware will
always detect conflicts between
currently running
regions and so if it performed that
reordering within there it would still
notice that it conflicted with another
region that was executing concurrently
so the hardware would be required to do
the effective same effective Thing If It
reorder the region right to to to insert
a region of its own it won't insert the
region because the compiler is already
inserted
regions so it's respons so the compiler
has inserted regions every every line of
code in the program progr is in a
region and as long the basic idea is
that as long as there's no conflicts
between concurrently executing regions
then you actually have a region
serializable execution and it doesn't
matter whether or not it was the
compiler that reordered those things the
only thing is that the hardware is only
allowed to do those reorderings within
the regions that the compiler
inserted so if if it the compiler didn't
reorder it would put one region around
each statement for example and the
hardware would not be allowed regions at
all that's correct only re within a that
correct understand make sense
okay okay
um so yeah we formalized these
requirements for the compiler and the
hardware and then use those to establish
that indeed these you know if the
compiler and the hardware meet these
requirements then we get this this end
to-end guarantees that we want to give
the programmer and that is that a data
race free source level program implies
that there will be no memory model
exception raised at runtime for any
execution of that program and
furthermore if an execution goes through
without raising a memory model exception
then that execution is sequentially
consistent with respect to the source
program
okay um so I claimed that this um this
restricted form of race detection was
efficient uh and and simple and it is
and in fact there's an analogy here with
Hardware transactional memory
um in Hardware transactional memory we
have these transactions that are running
concurrently and you have to detect
conflicts between them uh and then roll
back and reexecute a transaction uh if
conflicts are detected and we actually
do something very similar here but it's
actually simpler because some of the
difficulty in implementing Hardware
transactional memory is doing
checkpointing and having to roll back
transactions um here we don't have any
roll back we actually are able to
terminate the program because we can
guarantee there's a data rate
um also another source of difficulty in
implementing transactional memory is
because the programmer is controlling
the boundaries of transactions they can
be arbitrarily large uh but the hardware
only has bounded resources to work with
so there has to be some sort of fallback
mechanism here we actually our compiler
is inserting the region fences and so we
can actually bound the size of these
regions and that's exactly what we do
and this is why you might want to put in
region fences where
uh even where there aren't
synchronization
operations uh and so this by bounding uh
the number of memory locations that are
accessed in any particular region uh we
ease the the the hardware the job of the
hardware um and the disadvantage to this
is that we are still we're limiting the
compiler to optimize only within regions
so we're sort of further limiting its
scope by by bounding these
regions but we would like it if the
hardware wasn't necessar neily required
to uh to limit its scope of
optimizations and so we actually
distinguish these bounding region fences
from the region fences we insert for
synchronization so that the hardware can
actually coales these regions at runtime
if the conservative compiler analysis if
it has resources available either
because it has a lot of uh resources
dedicated to conflict detection or
because the compiler was conservative in
its bounding
analysis a question so so if the hard
right do you insert in the compiler if I
mean I don't understand why would you
compute the expounds in the compiler not
just do it in the hard
very because the compiler has to agree
not to reorder accesses across the
regions otherwise we can't get the end
to end we could get we could get
sequential consistency for the compiled
program but not for the original Source
program
okay um does this mean that you can't
put Loops inside regions so this is this
is is the case for our implementation
that brings me nicely to the next slide
um so we we took llvm and we did this
naive bounding analysis and for this
analysis we we did put a region fence at
every loop back Edge so essentially you
have a single iteration of loop um now
this is not this is this is naive and
you could do something else you could
unroll the loop uh and have several
iterations be in a in a region and then
you know uh loop that way so we just
have an elemented uh these more advanced
features to make the the analysis well
not even the analysis but just make the
insertion of region fences better um and
uh yeah and so I I so so those fences
that the compiler inserts for the reason
you just mentioned really are very
different in the sense that comper is
actually telling the hardware you may
put a bandary here because I didn't
reorder AC cross it yes it doesn't mean
the hardware has to put it that's
exactly right so the hardware is
actually still still able to do
reordering as long as it has resources
available to do this conflict detection
over the larger
region yeah so that's I mean that's
maybe we'll explain why we don't see
such a huge performance loss um when we
are doing this sort of putting this this
naive thing of putting a a fence at
every back edges because the hardware is
still able to do all the reordering it
wants across those uh loop iterations as
long as it has the
resources um okay so for the so that's
what we did for the compiler um based on
llvm for the uh Hardware we simulated
this in
fes2 uh and uh we used a lazy uh
conflict detection and did this region
coalescing that we're talking about when
when possible and we measured the
performance on these parallel benchmarks
uh parek and splash 2 um and parseek in
particular is is supposed to capture you
know the the types of programs will be
running on multi-core machines uh the
emerging workloads for those kind of
machines
so these are the results we
saw um on average 9% slowdown uh the
blue portion of this bar roughly
corresponds to the the overhead that was
caused by lost optimization
opportunities in the compiler so because
the compiler being restricted to these
regions uh it's not able to do all of
the the optimization it normally would
and so that's what the the blue portion
of the bar represents the red portion is
from the Lost hardware optimizations and
the additional cost that the hardware
has to incur for doing this uh Hardware
uh conflict detection this sort of race
detection so if we were to improve the
the way in which we're inserting these
bounding fences I think that there's a
lot of hope that we could get this blue
section of the bar to shrink uh further
than it is now and actually bring these
overheads
down yeah your last sentence there in
other words you don't think that is the
case that the that those optimizations
would destroy the the um the correctness
of the program in in these cases
um if if there if there was a data race
in that Loop then you might be more
likely to raise a memory model exception
at runtime because you're doing conflict
detection over larger
regions uh and you may have broken it by
doing some of those optimizations but
we're going to catch
it but um but you think that so these
programs may have such such bugs they
may have such bugs I I think we did
counter uh a race in one or two of these
benchmarks that seem to be an
intentional race um that was in there
but for the most part these are these
are Race Free programs and so these you
know this really is just lost
optimization
potential yeah so did you compiler do
some un Rollings to get over this limit
it did not it hasn't yeah we haven't
done that
yet okay so
so for a summary of this drfx stuff um
this idea of having the compiler
communicate to the hardware regions
where it might have performed
optimizations and then doing a
lightweight form of data race detection
along with this freedom to raise an
exception and terminate a program on
racy execution gives us a memory model
that's easy to understand both for
programmers and compiler writers the
programmer is going to get
understandable SC behavior for all
programs unless of course they're termin
in which Cas they know they definitely
have a data race in their program and
the compiler is allowed to perform all
its favorite sequentially valid
optimizations without tricky reasoning
like you have to do in the Java memory
model with a few
restrictions um and it's efficient you
know because it admits all of these
optimizations um and because the
detection that we have to do in Hardware
is actually fairly simple and so we saw
this that we only saw a 9% slowdown on
average so which I think is a you know a
reasonable price to pay for an
understandable memory model
yeah just a general question so from my
point of view as a programmer where I
want to just write reliable programs
it's made it um it's great that it'll
either execute correctly or it will fail
but I still am not guaranteed when I've
written a given program and even done
fairly exhaustive testing that it might
not raise this memory model exception
out in the field and still fail in some
uh you know in some real world condition
and still cause some problems I'm
guaranteeing
it's nice that it's going to either go
correct or it's going to really really
fail but I still if I want to write
something that will be reliable I still
have this issue of can I test to find
all of the possible PS is that correct
yes you do H and and I think that that
still would be a a problem that you
would want to address I mean I think
it's still worth looking for data races
even when you have a memory model like
this perhaps even more so um because you
don't want to have these kind of crashes
in the field I mean there are
compromises that you could think of you
know you could you could use uh drfx for
development and then say if you think
that it's better that you're program
limp along in the field you know not not
do this conflict detection I don't know
if I would recommend that because that
would just make that more difficult to
debug um but you know that is you know
that's an interesting um point in this
but I don't know that it's any worse
than saying that your program can Branch
to arbitrary code and start executing
either so um
yeah all right um so if there are no
other questions on on the drfx portion
so far yes sebas one more question so
you you talked about synchronization
option operations have to be in their
own region what what do you include in
that group of synchronization operations
um well we would include all of your
low-level sort of compar and swap
interlocked operations those would need
to be in their own uh in addition to um
Library calls to something like lock in
on unlock um and things like
this
so what what about I like inside the
Library called to lock or unlock you're
going to have databases right because
these things may read in right
locations so I think that we can do so
there's two different approaches you
could take here you could say you could
say that the libraries are not subject
to the drfx and and and sort of isolate
uh them and say that that you just put
those in own region you could also
choose to actually only put lock and
unlock or sorry uh only consider the
lowest level machine instructions as
being um as being synchronization
operations and then insist that those
lock and unlock actually be coded in a
way that there were no you know quote
unquote benign races or or races that
people uh you know considered the
underlying machines memory model to get
correct you know that you actually had
to have used the atomic operation
uh in our in our tests these thre these
programs were using p threads and we did
not um recompile a p threads library and
we we put those calls in in
regions okay um so I'm going to move on
to talk about light race uh which uses
uh a sampling approach in order to make
data race detection light uh
lightweight so we don't have drfx
Hardware it you know drfx requires
Hardware support so what can we do in
the meanwhile um well one thing we can
do is we can try and find data races
using software
tools uh and you know we want to find
data races for multiple reasons first of
all because of these you know the
exposure to these weak memory model
effects that we were talking about all
through Dr effects these reorderings and
unintuitive behaviors um but even if you
had sequentially consistent semantics
data races still can indicate bugs
because often times times they they
indicate some violation of a highlevel
consistency property for instance if you
don't have um mutex locks uh inserted to
protect the state of an object uh is
consistent um so you still want to find
data races even if you had SC and
especially when you don't have
SC uh and as I mentioned earlier static
techniques are rarely used um you know
it's it's an active area of research and
there's uh good work in in uh type
systems for avoiding races uh in lock
based code um but for code that doesn't
use locks then you're sort of um left
out in a cold and
so that's where Dynamic race detection
uh has some advantages it's able to
support easily support any kind of
synchronization down to lowlevel compare
and swaps um and when it when they
report a race Dynamic race detectors are
capable of doing that with having no
false
positives uh on the downside uh Dynamic
race detection has low coverage because
it only you know it's only run on the
test cases that you uh that you give it
uh and only on certain inner leavings uh
and so you can miss bugs and in addition
there's also very high overhead uh for
doing Dynamic race detection precise
detectors you know the fastest ones slow
down an application by 8X uh and some of
them out there are you know 50x or
100x uh and so as a result developers
and testers are unlikely to use these uh
these tools
uh and so light race the goal here was
to sort of keep these advantages that
Dynamic detection has and mitigate some
of these disadvantages uh and the idea
is that if we can make it lightweight
enough then we can increase the coverage
by running it all the time maybe even
during beta deployment um and uh and we
also want to maintain this this feature
of dynamic race detection that we're
able to support all of the different
synchronization
Primitives it's also Al very important
that we uh that we don't give false
positives because we want to the last
thing we want to do is send developers
on a wild goose chase looking for a race
that doesn't exist uh that's not a way
to get people to use your tool uh and we
found that this sampling approach was
actually effective here we were able to
run it on uh x86 binaries we run it on
Apache and Firefox uh on these
concurrency runtime for net and uh the
dryad distributed application framework
uh and ended up finding 70% of the races
that were present in a particular that
were exhibited in a particular execution
by sampling only 2% uh uh 2% sampling
rate and that translated into a 28%
slowdown versus a 7 and a2x slowdown for
the fastest full data race detector we
could
build so here's what the architecture
looked like um we we take an x86 binary
and we instrument it uh to log events of
Interest which in this case are memory
accesses and synchronization operations
then we we generate uh at runtime a log
of these events which we then postmortem
after the execution analyze using
happens before race detection uh to
report races and the idea of using
sampling then of course is to reduce the
number of events that we have to analyze
and that should speed up this part of
the code and also the detection
process so sampling has been shown to be
effective in other contexts um so in
profile guided optimization for instance
uh this has been very effective and uh
in asl4
um the SWAT tool was introduced which
found uh memory uh memory leak bugs uh
using sampling very effectively but it's
not clear that you can apply this
technique easily in the domain of race
detection and the problem is that you
know most accesses don't participate in
a race and furthermore by definition we
need to capture two accesses the two
racing accesses in order to do this and
at the same time we want to avoid these
false positives uh and I'll I'll explain
why that we have to be careful careful
with that in a
moment so let's take a look at what uh
happens before race detection looks like
um so here's a graph of two threads uh
and program order creates happens before
edges within a thread uh and then
synchronization operations induce
happens before edges across threads and
here we have a properly synchronized
program that uses locks to make sure
that you're not writing X at the same
time that you're reading x and we know
that there's no race here because we can
actually draw a path uh between these
two accesses in our happens before graph
if we had an unprotected access outside
then we have a data race because we
can't draw a path between them so we can
see why this is why Dynamic happens
before race detection is very very
expensive and that's because we have to
monitor you know we have to do some
extra work at every synchronization
operation and every memory
access so we want to use sampling to get
rid of some of these and we notice that
you know if we if we miss one of these
memory accesses well we might miss this
data race here for instance if we didn't
log this read of X but we're already
missing bugs we're in a dynamic analysis
we're only testing some paths so maybe
if this doesn't happen too often we'll
we'll be okay with
that however if we were to not log one
of these lock operations for instance
well that can actually affect the
happens before graph and so we can you
know end up reporting a false race
between these things that are actually
properly synchronized so the bottom line
is is uh we use sampling for the memory
accesses but we do not sample
synchronization operations we log every
synchronization operation that
happens so how are we going to do this
sampling um we want to find both of
these accesses and have a low sampling
rate so the first thing that I tried was
well why don't I see how random works
and it actually wasn't nearly as bad as
I expected it to be um with a 10% random
sample rate we detected around 25% of
the races that were exhibited during an
execution and if you bump that up to 25%
we found 45% of the races but I should
point out that this is still you know if
you're if you're logging a quarter of
the memory accesses are in your program
you're going to slow down your program a
whole lot so this is not really great
and in fact we can do a whole lot better
uh we end up sampling only around 2% of
memory accesses and still finding 70% of
the races in the
program uh yeah how do you do the
sampling um so the sampling is is B B on
this cold path hypothesis okay and what
we we consider code to be cold if it
hasn't been executed before uh in a
particular thread okay and that was
important it turns out that we did this
per thread um and sort of the hypothesis
was if especially if you have a well
tested program then the races between
hot paths are already going to have been
found and fixed um and that we want to
focus our effort on these uh per thread
cold paths
what's the cost of logging all the
synchronization
operation um
so well I mean the cost of logging all
of the synchronization operations plus
the 2% of the memory accesses ended up
being a 28% slowdown on average uh over
our benchmarks and it varied a bit and
so among this 28% most of it then is due
to the SE yeah I I would say that that
is true I don't remember if I this has
been a while since I did this I don't
remember if I looked at exact
I think I did break down exactly what
the what the synchronization cost was
versus the memory uh but I would say
that most of it was due to
that
um right so here uh here are those
results uh that we got this first these
first two columns were calculated by
running a special version of the tool
that actually logged all accesses so
that means it's actually performing full
full data race detection
uh but notice noting along the way which
of those accesses would have been
sampled by our sampler uh we then find
all of the distinct pairs of racing
instructions that were exhibited during
that execution and see the percentage of
those that were found uh by the sampled
if we only used the memory accesses that
would have been sampled and so that's
how we get this number of an average of
of 70% 67% uh of the races exhibited
during a particular execution found by
our sampler uh and then this is the the
effective number of memory accesses that
were logged in each of those
applications um and then of course over
here we did you know the the regular
tool without doing the full logging to
see what its performance would be and
then this full logging slowdown was we
took out all of the overhead of sampling
and deciding whether we were sampling or
not and just did as fast as we could you
know using the same infrastructure sort
of to log all of the memory accesses uh
and the synon ization operations so
doing that full logging we slowed down
72x uh as opposed to just 28%
slowdown uh for the light race version
so how do you know how many race like
how do you know all you know all the
races I know all the races that happen
during a particular execution that are
exhibited during a particular execution
okay so you like a a separate
tool it's it was it was a tool that did
yes it was a tool that did that logged
all memory accesses and all
synchronization operations and so from
that I can do happens before R
detection uh and and exhaustively find
all of the races that were exhibited dur
that ex Bic um well you'll you have to
argue with a developer to tell them that
they're bucks uh we I mean we did have
some you know we did find
something that that at least we could
get people to admit were performance
problems um because of these races like
missing us scheduling something because
of a race or something like that firks
are say to use even though there're a
bunch of I I I don't think so I think
that they I I think that we should aim
for having absolutely data Race Free
programs I mean that's that's why drfx
seems like a reasonable memory model for
me um but it's kind of funny right you
make this race Checker so you even say
how many you find like of the real races
and
then uh you're basic say nothing happens
right like no one really cares about
that that they're
races
yeah I wish that we could change that uh
that perception I really do think that
it's going to get worse as we get as we
get more and more concurrency going on
these data races actually may you know
exhibit real problematic Behavior so
you're saying like it just in real
executions you almost never observe the
bad behavior right because the race you
know just H you know needs to happen
right and then even get like bad
results I think that the problem is that
the developers think at least they have
thought the race through and have
determined that you know even though
it's a race it will not cause any
har so if they're right or not is a
completely different question but that's
why they will fix it so if they're right
it means like race detectors are not
useful if they're wrong
right so I'm kind of wondering like how
many races are actually denied right
yeah and I think that's an excellent
question and it's something that we kind
of struggled with in izing this because
you know diving into a a code base like
this that's large and then trying to
determine whether some race report is is
potentially benign you know my my
initial reaction because of just my
attitude towards the data races is you
shouldn't be programming with data races
so this isn't a benign race but you know
looking at that with like okay if I
really reason about this do I think it
can exhibit uh bad behavior that's
difficult to do and so I would I would
like to know how many of these were
quote unquote open n or intentional
change right with the with newer tips or
architectur or
memory you know for sure so so what
would you recommend to a programmer who
want who is saying I'm writing a a lock
implementation myself and I want to make
it really efficient and I know that if I
use interlock for everything it's not
going to be performing the way it should
I I I know I need to like use regular
loads first to test for example if it's
free so what should I do to to write
this
lock well I mean that's that's a
difficult question I mean that that's a
practical issue that we're that that you
have to deal with now you know I mean I
I would say long term you want to take
away the incentive for doing something
like that you want to you want to say
you know have your Hardware or your
compiler be smart enough that it can do
you know it can make a high performing
lock for you with you saying exactly you
know the compiler should take over
responsibility for alln low level
synchronization that would be nice and I
and I don't you know I don't think that
when it comes to systems code that's
always going to be feasible I think
you're always going to have someone that
needs to get their hands in at the low
level and do some of the stuff and for
that you know you know I don't think
that this necessarily addresses that but
I mean you I I ideally you want to be
able to verify that using something I
think you have a tool for for you know
verifying that Fen is you know
you have the right fences in so I mean
lowlevel verification would be great I
think that bottom line is I also think
that you need to have the
developer explicitly annotating this
this kind of behavior in in a readable
way for so that tools are able to reason
about it and help that I think that
that's
key yeah so these uh percent of races
found are are percent I'm curious can
you give us an intuition on the raw
counts I mean were like tens or hundreds
or for most of these executions
um so let me distinguish between first
of all a particular static what I'll
call a static data rase between two
lines of code May exhibit itself many
times during an execution uh and so I
think for some of these you're talking
about you know definitely hundreds if
you count repetitions if you just count
the number of static which is what I'm
doing here um because generally the
sampling version you know only found a
couple of one that was was uh exhibited
a lot of times in the in the full
logging uh
then you know I think that when it you
know for like concert and dryad I think
it was down around 15 you know that kind
of uh order of magnitude static uh it's
static so did you take a look at any of
these or and see if they were in for
instance the bug reports uh or file bug
reports um I did not see if any of them
were in the file bug bug reports for
Firefox for concert we did track back
one of them and go to the developers and
uh and and they were convinced that it
was benign in a sense but that you know
a task that was ready to be scheduled
wouldn't be picked up for some delayed
amount of time because of the race um
but they were willing to live with
that did you get an understanding that
the willing to live with that was from
performance reasons was that their kind
of
push I also think that people don't like
to fix races because it's not always
easy to do um you don't you don't know
exactly what synchronization you want to
introduce where without causing uh you
know being very C drained and causing a
lot of uh performance
penalty yeah is there any way that you
can um to test to your drfx model on
these actual runs and see which runs of
these races that you measured in the
full logging were actually still
substantially
consistent that's interesting to see to
see whether they were happens before
races that were very far apart you mean
so that they wouldn't cause any problem
that would be an interesting way to
combine this yeah but you don't have
that I don't have that
information um so quickly I'm not going
to just describe all these different
Samplers that we use but I just wanted
to show this because it's kind of a cool
graph um these cold path hypothesis uh
Samplers are these two on the left uh
the bar shows the percentage of data
races that they found in executions and
the dot shows the percentage of memory
accesses that were sampled so you want a
DOT close to the bottom and a tall bar
so these obviously are doing pretty well
um just forun I did this unold path
sampler which logged everything except
for the ones that would have been logged
by a cold path sampler to see what
happened and obviously you know we 99%
of the memory accesses were logged and
we still only found you know a third of
the races that exhibited in the program
and I I don't have any really deep idea
of exactly why this is the case but it
is good empirical evidence that this
cold path hypothesis has uh is is is
reasonable
um
um so just real quickly um you know do
this mean that you at least are going to
miss 30% of all the races in your
corre no because of this idea that um a
static race May exhibit itself multiple
times during an execution yes
exactly well but since it's static why
would if you have a hot hot race then
this will not be measured for their
system or just with lower frequency with
lower frequency adaptably backs
off
um so I'm going to just quickly sort of
position this with some of the related
work uh both drfx and light race um
obviously drfx is is a continuation of
all the work that's been done in memory
models both you know at the hardware
level and at the programming uh language
level and you know what we wanted to do
was give as strong a guarantee as we
could while still allowing uh a lot of
these optimizations and and this um and
by using this idea of race detection and
so there's been also a lot of work in in
hardware and software race detection but
none of those Solutions were either uh
High performing enough to use in drfx or
if they sacrificed Precision they didn't
do it in a way that we could sort of
harness to still give strong guarantees
so we had to sort of you know um do
something different there obviously
light waste is a software race detection
tool and it was the first one uh that
used sampling in order to make things
lightweight um there was work back in
the early 90s on detecting SC violations
that we were inspired by for the drfx
work where uh in the hardware they
detected races between inflight
instructions in the processors and then
terminated the the or reported a race uh
or terminated the program if that was
the uh if that happened um and so our
Insight here was okay how are we going
that that only gives you SC for the
compiled binary how are we going to
raise that all the way up to the
programming language level to give an
end to-end guarantee and so the idea of
region
was key there in order to allow that to
happen um there's also been other work
on memory model exceptions we're not the
first to suggest that it would be nice
if we could terminate a program when
there was a data race um and that's been
suggested in in the context of full data
race detection and then in work that was
concurrent with ours uh in this conflict
exception work by uh Luchia at
all um they do something very similar
where they detect concurrent conflicts
between between regions but they don't
do this bounding uh that we do and in
fact they that allows them to give a
slightly stronger guarantee which is
serializability of synchronization free
regions of code the trade-off for that
is that they have to handle this sort of
unbounded detection scheme and it makes
the hardware more
complex so I'm running a little long so
I'll try and and quickly finish up here
but I'm going to discuss a little bit
about some ongoing work uh and and
future
work
so I wanted to pose the question is SC
actually too slow this is kind of the
what drf Z models and drfx work you know
we all sort of are working under this
assumption that you know if you try and
do SC then you can't do all of these
optimizations and your code is going to
perform horribly so but then you know
you notice that in the hardware
Community there's been all this
architecture research that shows uh how
you can really reduce the gap between uh
a model like SC and a really weak memory
model like release
consistency um and and it's not just in
the research I mean in fact x86 provides
a variant of TSO which in many senses is
a very strong memory model uh it's not
it's not as strong as SC but it has a
straightforward operational semantics
that's recently been described um it's
easier to understand than for instance
the Java memory model uh and clearly
it's giving stronger guarantees to than
the C++ Ox memory model because it
doesn't behave arbitrarily in the face
of data races um so if the hardware
Community is able to to do this maybe
the compiler is where we're going to
lose all our performance so you know
what's going to happen if we try and
make an sc preserving
compiler um and so the idea here was I'm
going to take llvm which is a
state-of-the-art optimizing C
compiler um and then check every
transformation every optimization that
it does for its potential to reorder
accesses to Shared
memory then disabled passes or ified
them to be SC preserving because uh you
only have to disable the pass for
instance for shared variables you can
still allow reorderings of local
variables so that's what I did when I
was modifying these passes uh and this
included things like Loop inv variant
code motion Global value numbering which
does a form of common sub expression
elimination um and and many other passes
um and so I took this new compiler which
I should distinguish this from like
other work in SC compilers that actually
insert fences to make sure that your
program behaves SC on a particular
architecture because that is not what
this is doing this is just not
performing any non-sc optimizations
itself um and then I measured The
Slowdown of this compiler this
restricted compiler uh when running on
stock Hardware uh over fully optimized
version of llvm and there these are the
results that I saw over the Parc Splash
benchmarks on average a two or 2 and a
half%
Slowdown um now there's you know this
face Sim application see a 35% slowdown
uh which is pretty severe but for most
applications it looks okay and in fact
you know in some cases the compiler
appears to have been stepping on its
toes a little bit and get slightly
better performance when we disable some
of these
optimizations so Le 2 and a half% too
much to pay for an understandable memory
model I would say absolutely not
um 35% might be though so if you're
really interested in writing faim uh
then maybe that's that's going to be a
problem uh so I was thinking you know
Hardware it man manages to close the gap
by performing optimizations
optimistically under the assumption that
there are no data races and then
recovering if there's a potential race
encountered at runtime and it does this
by monitoring cach traffic and so it
says you know if if if no one has
accessed this cach line since I got it
then everything's okay my optimization
was okay otherwise I squash computation
and
re-execute we can actually allow if we
can change the hardware so it actually
exposes this mechanism to the
compiler um then we can actually do the
same kind of thing in the compiler where
we optimistically optimize and then if
we notice a uh if we notice a race then
we roll back and execute unoptimized
code and that actually allowed us to
reduce the overhead on face Sim by half
just by applying this technique to a
single optimization pass uh the the
common sub expression elimination or
Global value numbering pass actually uh
in
llvm um so just before concluding here I
I want want to point to this quote by uh
by Serita adve and Hans B who both have
a lot of experience like working in this
area of memory models Ser is very
instrumental in the Java memory model
and Hans in in the C++ Ox memory model
uh and in their Communications at the
ACM article recently they said we
believe a more fundamental solution to
the problem will emerge with a
co-designed approach where future
multi-core Hardware research evolves in
concert with the software models
research um and this is exactly you know
what what we were doing in drfx uh and I
think to very effect and I think that we
can continue to do that um into the
future uh now in the near term I I would
like to think about ways of adding
additional flexibility to the drfx
memory model um you know is there a way
that we can support sort of explicit
benign races in the program without
allowing those to sort of bleed in and
violate our safety guarantees that we
want to uh provide you know or is there
sort of an an analog to the C++
low-level atomics um that that gives us
more information about exactly how
synchronizations are being used um in
terms of this SC preserving compilation
I think we we need to sort of this is a
surprising result this this thing that
on average we're only seeing a 2%
slowdown by disabling all these
optimizations so we need to keep on
doing this on on some more benchmarks
and sort of see exactly which
optimizations are important in what
situations uh and additionally I'd like
to be able to sort of formally capture
exactly what kind of
optimizations um allow these
interference checks which are the the
mechanism that most was talking about
that allows the hardware to the compiler
to do the thing similar to the hardware
to optimize uh optimistically and then
roll back if interference was
encountered um and then you know more
long term I I think that this idea of
this holistic approach of considering
all levels of the of the programming
stack is going to be really important um
and I think we need to allow programmers
to express their the intended concurrent
behavior of a program or the intended
synchronization discipline to express
that in a machine readable format at the
high level um you know in some cases for
many applications hopefully that takes
the form of some kind of a declarative
uh description of the parallelism they
want to see but for some low-level
system stuff you know we may still need
to have uh low-level synchronization
disciplines like read copy update but
then hopefully we can communicate
exactly how we're intending this
discipline to work so that uh our
compilers and static analysis tools can
take advantage of it um you know in the
case over here of the of the more high
level parallelism descriptions then you
know the compiler can take care of
generating High performing low-level uh
parallel code and over here you know
hopefully we can flag discipline
violations and bugs that uh that the
systems programmer was unaware of uh and
I also think that there's there's
definitely more opportunity here at the
interface between the architecture uh
and the compiler for um for for getting
higher performance out of our parallel
programs for instance you know maybe
having the compiler distinguish local
variables uh from shared variable
accesses somehow uh to the architecture
so that it's able to perform more
aggressive optimizations on local things
just like the compiler can uh or somehow
communicate memory sharing patterns to
get um better performance uh and in
short uh and I think that this applies
you know not just to multi-core
architectures but all the future
architectures that we're going to
see um so you know together by taking
this holistic approach across the stack
and and hopefully harnessing some
cooperation um we can get programmers to
develop fast and safe concurrent systems
and that's
it yeah he report like a 90% overhead of
U of the the hardware and the the miss
software the Mis compiler optimizations
in the in the first part for the the rfx
um you also said later that the um that
you that no one would write um programs
the basis at all and indeed the um I
mean the the number of programmers who
write program s with races um
intentionally I mean must be a very
small part of the population so my
question is is it is it worth it to
complicate the um the hardware um and
get those slowdowns uh just so that we
can accommodate those um few programs WR
in that way or are there are there
better ways to harvest those
bugs well I
would so what I'm worried about are the
programmers that are not intending to
write programs that way and are actually
writing racy programs
unintentionally and that's where I think
that this can be very now I mean if your
question is if I had static techniques
that allowed me to guarantee race-free
programs while still being expressive
and high performance then I say that
that that is great uh but it's proved
very difficult uh to try and Achieve
that and so I think that um whether
whether it's drfx or some other
technique I think this idea of of
leaning on the hardware a little bit to
to let us do this uh you know more
easily is reasonable um so let's see so
if the if the programmers don't intend
the races I mean they should they should
have used better programming constructs
probably like I mean box maybe or
something but the but if they're um if
they have races in their programs and
even they said perhaps intended to use
Lots uh then seems like the light race
would be a a better attack to um to find
those bugs and change the programs right
although I mean I I agree uh although
the problem with that is that there's
you're still not guaranteeing that
you're going to find all the races but
even if you can if you guaranteed
sequential consistency if the
programmer uh did not realize that there
were races in the in the program to
begin with the i the program probably
isn't correct right that's true and uh
uh but but the I mean the nice thing
there though is at least you can reason
uh you can reason in that natural
intuitive way about what you're seeing
happen you know you can say okay this
must have happened before this which
happened before this and then it got
interleaved this way as opposed to
thinking this statement could have
arbitrarily executed early that's why
I'm seeing this value in this register
so I mean it it really does become a
debugging nightmare when you have these
weak memory model
effects
okay thank you
thanks